five things all potential actresses must
do
when they get to la oh
must do and and should do before they
get here
you know basically whatever you can do
before um
you know you're gonna need obviously a
place where you
to stay um that's your sanctuary you're
safe
um you're living with you know if you
have a roommate that they're normal
um that would be the number one just
because that's you know your
your security um figure out what you're
going to do for a job that's going to be
actor-friendly
if you're going to move to la do not
take a full-time job unless you know
that you're going gonna be able to
quit it after three months or you know
give yourself leeway so that you can
save up
whatever that is um really try to
think of all different kinds of jobs
that you can do either from home or
um you know very part-time taskrabbiting
or
nannying or you know where you get to
choose your hours some of the time
um that and find either an improv
class um improv group i mean usually
it's one in the same
um or comedy intensive um
on camera if you don't want to focus on
comedy intensive but
on camera intensive as well those things
are
super important
you